all right welcome back everybody there
is a look at Dodger Stadium and that's
where the World Series is heading next
game three Friday 7:30 eastern time
James code Dan heli and former Dodgers
general manager Ned Colletti is with us
now
so many takeaways I guess from these
first two games not many of them have
been positive Dodger takeaways but you
feel like just coming back here in the
cozy confines of Dodger Stadium
especially with the weather gonna be 40
degrees warmer gonna be a big deal for
these guys
I think it's whenever you're at home
this time of year it's a big it is a big
deal and I think I think the weather has
played a little bit of a role in it you
know Clayton Kershaw has developed a
great curveball but tough to use it when
the weather's the way the way the
weather's been Madsen really the
change-up is what they put back into his
his arsenal right tough to use that so I
think getting home it's always better to
be at home that's why you play all year
to get home-field advantage so you've
got a chance to win more at home do you
go right back to Madson it in Game three
if you need to or do you just you let
him have a little break no I don't think
you have a time for a break right now I
think I think you go by whatever the
game is telling you you need to do and
sometimes you need to stop the game in
the middle of the game sometimes you
need to stop a rally in the fifth inning
sure um times that's where it goes
you'll see a closer once in a while
pitch to 8th sometimes because that's
where the lineup is coming up that's
where you got a chance to win the game
or stop a rally I think that rally last
night came out of nowhere really
you got baskets hitting 200 through in
the regular season you got two outs in
the fifth and suddenly now you've got a
whole different dynamic on completely
different yep Ned Colletti joining us
here on the Rich Eisen show Ned talked
to us about you know the decision to not
necessarily start Cody Bellinger you see
joc pederson not starting I mean that's
a lot of power on that bench I mean when
you only get one at-bat for these guys
it's just I think a lot of traditional
baseball heads are scratching their
heads thinking why would you do this
I understand you know you've got you
know four left-handed hitters on that
bench last night that had about a
hundred and ten home runs combined I
mean that's a lot of power specially for
hitters ballpark yeah and
you know but they play match up baseball
all the time I mean it's a different way
of looking at it and you know to I think
where it gets a little bit tougher is
when you try to put somebody in the
middle or the later part of a game right
if you look at their bull Boston's
bullpen Kelly hundred miles an hour he
of all the hundred miles an hour
Kimbrel tremendous slider 98 miles an
hour that's a lot of guys to catch up
with when you've been sitting in the
cold for a few hours waiting to get an
opportunity you can swing in a cage all
night long and you can try to keep warm
by a heater but that's not like playing
the game so I think it is a little bit
tougher to do is it is it a situation
where I know it sounds a little
ridiculous because first of all a lot of
us are just watching this on TV so you
don't feel that cold but what you're
talking about is going beyond the
numbers and kind of reading that
situation a little bit playing it a
little bit more artistically in that way
so again I kind of look at that
situation as well and I said myself
you're right you know Joe Kelly's coming
out of the pen you know he's gonna be
throwing that gas face I mean you don't
necessarily know if he of Ali's gonna
come out but he's a weapon certainly out
of the bullpen you got to take into
consideration some of the external
factors beyond just what's on that
statute don't you always you always have
to do it especially this come here
everything is magnified all the scouting
is all turned up but not all your senses
are turned up a notch at this time of
the season and so you've got to take a
lot of different things into
consideration but it's easier to sit
here on the couch and talk about it I
got a family and have it you know come
as fast as it does people think baseball
is a slow game it is so fast in the
thought process of it but you know
adjusting is part of thing but the way
the Red Sox have gone about this has
been really phenomenal almost historical
when you think about what they've been
able to do with runners in scoring
position and to our mm Jay sustar today
and he talked about Ted Williams in 41
had that tremendous season at 406 and
his numbers the Red Sox with runners in
scoring position as a team this
postseason have done better than Ted
Williams did in lost season as one of
the greatest hitters one of the greatest
seasons for a hitter of all time that's
insane
how do you keep that going you know it's
up to them to do it but that's
that's been phenomenal that's been a
game-changer and I think what you're
talking about is is one three in the
lineup 333 is what they're batting with
with runners in scoring position
listen it's an analytics driven game
it's different than what James Koh and I
cover for a living which is the NFL and
they are incorporating more analytics in
a football but can you use too many
analytics when you leave your top four
homerun hitters and the NLCS MVP and
Bellinger on the bench for two games in
a row to start a game RV are you over
analyzing sometimes don't you just want
to get your best players out on the
field and let your players make plays
you know what it's it's such a deep
question it's sometimes it isn't
sometimes it isn't if they happen to
hold on to a two to one lead last night
our whole conversation you know it all
started with the same lineup so it's a
it's a tough thing to answer only
because there's so many different
factors that are involved in the
decision-making and they have so much
information you know we all have some
information they have so much
information that leads them to the
decisions that they make
they've won six straight Western titles
have been data LCS three times the world
series the last two they do have
something figured out there a lot of
teams don't have them straight out and
sometimes you know what sometimes
players also have to produce that's true
whoo-hooo is a guy that you look at on
this roster who not only needs to
perform but could be the one to perform
once they get here to LA would it would
it be a guy like Puig that you know very
well you know yasiel Puig I think he's
got a chance to like like the place up
we know how he plays your plays with the
great exuberance with new excitement
with great passion I think he's got a
shot I think a guy like Bellinger you
get Bellinger hot you get even jock one
of those who guys you get them hot at
this point in time it'll change the
series the World Series is such a any
any seven-game series of the side a
championship at the highest level is so
intriguing and interesting on a game by
game basis if this is one to one totally
different deal if it goes to two one
it's a totally
in situation the odd number games I
usually just have a little bit more
twist to them than the even number game
so you got an odd number game coming up
here she's gonna be 300 or it's gonna be
2 to 1 where a little bit of pressure
starts to find its way back to Boston
because then they're gonna have to
probably win another game at this place
Dodge's though they're in a hole because
they're gonna have to win a game at
Fenway Park if they're gonna win the
World Series at least one and maybe two
how important is playing with the lead
they had they had the lead for a moment
last night but when the Red Sox score
first they're practically unbeatable
yeah it's very important to have the
lead it's even more important to keep
the lead it's one thing to have because
you grab momentum and let's face it that
is a great momentum type of ballpark
very Park people right on top yeah they
got a great fan base there you get a
lead like they did last night
that's great cuz you can as as noise as
it can be it can get just as quiet can
you talk about that how to stop it you
can't give it back
can you talk about that atmosphere you
know not necessarily maybe in Fenway but
when you got a historic ballpark you
know something like Wrigley you know
what I mean do you feel those ghosts you
know what I think you feel the the
history of a place yeah and I think you
know especially Fenway there's no ball
park in America built like Fenway Park
right now it's got all the nooks and
crannies and scat though it's got the
Green Monster it's got the pesky pole
it's got right-center field that's
forever out there different wall sizes a
lot of different dynamics going on and
part of the beauty of baseball I think
you need to do a video leaked play but
you don't the dieters haven't been in
Fenway Park for a while a lot of those
players were there for the first time
and they're going to the Green Monster
in there checking it out and it's really
a cool experience sure but it's not it's
not a tour it's not a travel trip it's
like the biggest business trip of your
life you know and so it is you got to
get used to it you got to get accustomed
to it you don't have a chance to see it
during a season which i think is cool
for baseball that they do still divide
the two leagues and it doesn't divide it
up where you see Mookie Betts were
really the first time let you watch them
on TV or drove down to Anaheim to watch
and play the angels you're really kind
of seeing I'm true you're a nationally
fan for the first time Dodger fan you'll
learn about Mookie Betts JD my team's I
saw in Arizona
you're permitted but it's an interesting
interesting dynamic that they create by
doing what they do but historic
ballparks they're they're pretty cool a
lot of buzz last night after the game
about mookie betts possibly playing
second base when they get here if you're
the Red Sox would that be a move that
then you made undoubtedly I think he's a
tremendous athlete that's where he came
up he played a little bit until 2014 I
think he was a second baseman so he's
familiar with it I'm sure you know they
just didn't get on the flight last night
and say hey Mookie you think about
playing second base when you get there
Friday no I'm sure that they've been
thinking about it working with him he's
got Pedroia there that is obviously very
much involved yeah can help him get some
of the rough spots over to me the double
play will be his toughest challenge
especially with his back to the runner I
think that will be a challenge the rules
kind of support a player a little bit
more than they did as far as getting
blindside or getting getting run down in
my situation but I think that's the move
they're gonna make they have to keep him
in the lineup they got to keep JD
Martinez in the lines they got it in my
opinion the outfields got to be the
outfield that's got to be the same same
you got the same group of guys but
you've got to have JD Martinez play
instead it's a great problem to have by
the way Ockman asked this earlier who do
you start a team around mookie or JD
martinez you can lean I said about
Mookie and that's no that's no slam on
JD my JD my teen is a tremendous player
yeah Mookie better defensively
Mookie younger I don't think Mookie will
do what JD Martinez has done power-wise
run production-wise but you know you I
like to youth a little bit I like to the
WN will play defense defense a huge part
of the game gate game 3 7:30 Eastern on
Friday Rick Porcello against the 24 year
old rookie Walker Buehler and Bueller's
ace of the future of this kid this kid
is an absolute stud like David Price
also went to Vanderbilt when his
fastball is going he's hard to beat how
do you look at this matchup I think it's
gonna be a great matchup you've got a
veteran siyoung Award winner and
Porcello you've also got a young pitcher
and I agree with you this this kid has
got what I would call octo
over stuff some pictures that are that
don't throw quite as hard and don't have
quite as much sharpness to their
pictures they can win 1517 games from
April to 7 to September they get to the
postseason it's a different story people
team him up a little bit this kid is so
good he's got a high fastball a low
fastball with some great life to it
great slider breaking ball he knows how
to pitch too and he's also got a little
bit more of a characteristic to him that
I love at this time that's what I'm
talking yeah he's got some yeah he's not
a is a great kid but he's not a pleasant
performer he's got a little grit to him
and he got a head of grit this time of
year Dan Haley James Curle here on the
Rich Eisen showed Ned Colletti joining
us now a my craziness to see a little
bit of of Madison Bumgardner
in Walker Buehler man he you talk about
that nastiness you know what I mean you
talk about that heat that he can throw I
see a little bit of mad bomb in there no
doubt and I think that that that to me
is what separate I've been doing it on
the game for the decades and as I as I
separate the good from the great the
great from the iconic it's really a lot
of different things including having
that grit to mm-hmm and having that not
just grit on its own that that's got
some value but that you are able to take
the great ability you have and and
accentuate it accented by how you
prepare and how you how you play he's
done a lot of things this year
this kid has had a year word they didn't
even know if it was gonna be in the
rotation till later they're gonna pitch
him out of the pen he's done a lot of
pitching this year but he's been he's
been up to the test so he just just had
that big start in Milwaukee not too long
ago on that those are big moments in the
College World Series and and that's a
cool thing for a college kid but that
ain't the World Series but you know he's
he's certainly capable of really turning
the series around the numbers say it
doesn't bode well for the Dodgers teams
that have gone up to nothing in the
World Series have an 84 percent chance
to win that being said the numbers
didn't bode well for the Dodgers in May
that's where they were below 500 or in
several games in the postseason where
they were behind and came back to win do
you feel like those experiences will
indeed help them once they get back to
Dodgers
Stadium here I think every every season
is different and every team has got it's
its own fingerprint and and its own
style of play there were 16 and 26 I
think that was the worst record in the
history of the LA part of the franchise
you know that's that's pretty tough to
overcome they were in third place and
played in a tough division you had
Colorado it Arizona two teams have
battled all year long they had to play
160 third game to win a six straight
division they are kind of in tune with
let's do it the difficult way and all
those numbers yeah anybody can say you
know it's easy up to - nothing you got a
chance - you got a better chance to win
it than the team found Oh - but still
you know that's that's how history is
made - that's how history is made that
is how things have changed look at they
celebrated Dave Roberts stealing a base
the other day in Game four the LCS a
long time ago right
he stole a base Billy Miller one of my
dear friends singles amend against
Mariano Rivera history starts to be made
who thought that they were going to come
back from three down I know with with
two outs in a stolen base Dave Roberts
could live to be 200 years old he will
be known forever as the guy who sold
patientís you're on so that stuff is all
cool being down - albeit up - or
whatever it is but that's how history
gets made is when something like that
happens that you don't necessarily
expect or see all the time if the Red
Sox are able to hold on and win this
World Series the depth and the talent on
that roster we we talk about dynasties
so much some sports could this be a
dynasty in the making could this be a
team that could string together two or
three to do it I do have a lot of young
talent but it is tough to win people
think it's easier to win they haven't
had to do it it is tough to do they have
to figure out their bullpen at the end
of this year true Kimbrel is gonna be a
free agent
Uvalde is gonna be a free agent they've
got a lot of things that to think
through anything is possible but I think
in this day and age when you string
together consistent years of sustained
excellence that's special that's
probably that's far harder than coming
back down to games do you think that the
top floor homerun hitters Bellinger
Muncey Peterson and Crown dal will be on
the bench win Game three starts at now I
think you'll see at least
in the game right-handed pitcher going
to and you know so they they play it the
way they play and they've been ultra
successful doing it Ned Colletti thanks
so much for coming in my pleasure great
to be with just as good the puck [ __ ]
just learned that we're neighbors live
about five blocks apart and we're not
talking to York City blocks these are
these are tighter little blocks you're
from the backyard next that's Ned
Colletti thank you very much spectrum
Sports Net analyst right now perhaps a
general manager again in the future time
will tell but he's enjoying this TV
thing pretty damn good at it too
thanks Ned we appreciate it the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience